ANALYST AND FORMER COUNSEL TO
HOUSE DEMOCRATS IN THE FIRST
IMPEACHMENT.
ANDY, I DO WANT TO START WITH
YOU.
JUST THE BASICS HERE.
FOR THE FBI TO GET A WARRANT AND
GO SEARCH MAR-A-LAGO, WHAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN?
>> THE WORLD NEEDS TO MOVE.
I MEAN, I CAN'T OVEREMPHASIZE TO
YOU, JOHN, HOW BIG OF A DEAL
THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
FBI.
THIS IS NOT, YOU KNOW, A COUPLE
OF AGENTS SHOWING UP AT SOME
JUDGE'S DOOR IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT TO GET AN EMERGENCY
WARRANT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN PLANNED OUT AND
RE-EVALUATED AND LEGALLY
EXAMINED FROM EVERY POSSIBLE
ANGLE BY THE ENTIRETY OF THE
LEADERSHIP STRUCTURE OF BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS.
SO LET'S REMEMBER THAT TO GET A
SEARCH WARRANT IN ANY CASE,
WHETHER IT'S YOU OR I OR THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE TO GO
BEFORE A FEDERAL JUDGE AND
CONVINCE THAT JUDGE THAT THERE'S
PROBABLE CAUSE TO BELIEVE BOTH
THAT A FEDERAL CRIME HAS BEEN
COMMITTED AND THAT EVIDENCE OF
THAT CRIME IS CONTAINED WITHIN
THE SPACE YOU HAVE DESCRIBED IN
YOUR WARRANT REQUEST.
SO WE HAVE IN THIS SITUATION A
FEDERAL JUDGE MADE THAT
DETERMINATION, GIVING THE AGENTS
AUTHORITY TO ENTER THAT PREMISES
AND SEARCH EVERY PART OF THE
PREMISES THAT MIGHT CONTAIN THE
ITEMS THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY
DESCRIBED IN THE WARRANT.
SO IF IT'S, FOR INSTANCE,
DOCUMENTS, CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS,
THINGS LIKE THAT -- AND WE DON'T
KNOW, BUT THAT'S JUST A GUESS --
THEN YOU COULD SEE WHY THEY
WOULD HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
SEARCH EVERY SPACE, EVERY
DRAWER, EVERY SAFE, EVERY
CLOSET, EVERY DESK THAT MIGHT
CONTAIN THOSE DOCUMENTS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
NORM EISEN, THE REPORTING FROM
KAITLAN HERE THAT THIS RAID,
THIS FBI OPERATION IS IN
RELATION TO THE HANDLING OF
PRESIDENTIAL DOCUMENTS,
INCLUDING POSSIBLY CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, WHY MIGHT THAT MERIT
AN FBI OPERATION LIKE THIS AT
THE HOME OF A FORMER PRESIDENT?
>> WELL, JOHN, IN AMERICA,
NOBODY IS ABOVE THE LAW, AND THE
FEDERAL LAWS ARE VERY CLEAR THAT
ANYBODY WHO REMOVES, MUTILATES,
OR DESTROYS RECORDS, IT'S 18 USC
2071, IS SUBJECT TO PENALTIES,
INCLUDING CRIMINAL PENALTIES.
THERE'S EVEN MORE STRICT RULES
FOR CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS BEING
REMOVED FROM OFFICIAL PREMISES
BECAUSE OF THE DAMAGE THAT CAN
DO TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
WHEN I WAS THE WHITE HOUSE
ETHICS CZAR, THIS WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST THINGS THAT WE TRAINED
EVERYBODY IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION ON, STARTING
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE THE RULES ARE
THE SAME FOR EVERYON